The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES SWAN: OK.
Should we begin?
Let me remind you,
we switched topics.
We transitioned
from linear algebra,
solving systems of
linear equations,
to solving systems of
nonlinear equations.
And it turns out, linear algebra
is at the core of the way
that we're going to
solve these equations.
We need iterative approaches.
These problems are complicated.
We don't know how many
solutions there could be.
We have no idea where those
solutions could be located.
We have no exact
ways of finding them.
We use iterative methods to
transform non-linear equations
into simpler problems, right?
Iterates of systems
of linear equations.
And the key to that was
the Newton-Raphson method.
So I'm going to pick
up where we left off
with the Newton-Raphson
method, and we're
going find out ways of being
less Newton-Raphson-y in order
to overcome some difficulties
with the method, shortcomings
of the method.
There are a number
of them that have
to be overcome in various ways.
And you sort of choose these
so-called quasi- Newton-Raphson
methods as you need them.
OK, so you'll find out.
You try to solve a problem.
And the Newton-Raphson method
presents some difficulty,
you might resort to a quasi
Newton-Raphson method instead.
Built into MATLAB is
non-linear equations solver.
fsolve.
OK, it's going to
happily solve systems
of nonlinear equations
for you, and it's
going to use this
methodology to do it.
It's going to use
various aspects
of these quasi- Newton-Raphson
methods to do it.
I'll sort of point
out places where
fsolve will take
from our lecture
and implement them for you.
It will even use some more
complicated methods that
we'll talk about later on in
the context of optimization .
Somebody asked an
interesting question,
which is how many of
these nonlinear equations
am I going to want
to solve at once?
Right?
Like I have a system
of these equations.
What does a big system of
nonlinear equations look like?
And just like with
linear equations,
it's as big as you can imagine.
So one case you could think
about is trying to solve,
for example, the steady
Navia-Stokes equations.
That's a nonlinear
partial differential
equation for the velocity field
and the pressure in a fluid.
And a at Reynolds number,
that non-linearity
is going to present itself
in terms of inertial terms
that may even dominate the flow
characteristics in many places.
We'll learn ways of discretizing
partial differential
equations like that.
And so then, at each point in
the fluid we're interested in,
we're going to have a non-linear
equation that we have to solve.
So there's going to be a system
of these non-linear equations
that are coupled together.
How many points are
there going to be?
That's up to you, OK?
And so you're going to
need methods like this
to solve that.
It sounds very complicated.
So a lot of times
in fluid mechanics,
we have better ways of
going about doing it.
But in principle, we've have any
number of nonlinear equations
that we want to solve.
We discussed last time, the
new Newton-Raphson method,
which was based around
the idea of linearization.
We have these
nonlinear equations.
We don't know what
to do with them.
So let's linearize them, right?
If we have some guess for the
solution, which isn't perfect,
but it's our best
possible guess.
Let's look at the function
and find a linearized form
of the function and see where
that linearized form has
an intercept.
And we just have an Ansatz.
We guess that this
is a better solution
than the one we had before.
And we iterate.
It turns out you can
prove that this sort
of a strategy-- this
Newton-Raphson strategy
is locally convergent.
If I start with a guess
sufficiently close to the root,
you can prove mathematically
that this procedure
will terminate with a
solution at the root, right?
It's going to approach after
an infinite number of iterates,
the root.
That's wonderful.
It's locally convergent,
not globally convergent.
So this is one of those
problems that we discussed.
Take a second here, right?
Here's your
Newton-Raphson formula.
You've got it on your slides.
Take a second here and--
this is sort of interesting.
Derive the Babylonian
method, right?
Turns out the Babylonians
didn't know anything
about Newton-Raphson but they
had some good guesses for how
to find square roots, right?
Find the roots of an
equation like this.
See that you understand the
new Newton-Raphson method
by deriving the
Babylonian method, right?
The iterative method for
finding the square root of s
as the root of this equation.
Can you do it?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JAMES SWAN: Yes, you know
how to do this, right?
So calculate the derivative.
The derivative is 2x.
Here's our formula for
the iterative method.
Right?
So it's f of x
over f prime of x.
That sets the
magnitude of the stop.
The direction is
minus this magnitude.
It's in one d, so we either
go left or we go right.
Minus sets the direction.
We add that to our
previous guess.
And we have our
new iterate, right?
You substitute f and f prime,
and you can simplify this
down to the Babylonian
method, which said take
the average of x and s over x.
If I'm at the
root, both of these
should be square root of s.
And this quantity should
be zero exactly, right?
And you'll get your solution.
So that's the Babylonian
method, right?
It's just an extension of
the Newton-Raphson method.
It was pretty good
back in the day, right?
Quadratic convergence to
the square root of a number.
I mentioned early on
computers got really good
in computing square
roots at one point,
because somebody did
something kind of magic.
They came up with a scheme for
getting good initial guesses
for the square root.
This iterative method has to
start with some initial guess.
If it starts far away,
it'll take more iterations
to get there.
It'll get there, but it's
going to take more iterations
to get there.
That's undesirable if you're
trying to do fast calculations.
So somebody came up
with some magic scheme,
using floating point
mathematics, right?
They masked some of the bits
in the digits of these numbers.
A special number
to mask those bits.
They found that using
optimization, it turns out.
And they got really
good initial guesses,
and then it would
take one or two
iterations with the
Newton-Raphson method
to get 16 digits of accuracy.
That's pretty good.
But good initial
guesses are important.
We'll talk about that
next week on Wednesday.
Where do those good
initial guesses come from?
But sometimes we don't
have those available to us.
So what are some other
ways that we can improve
the Newton-Raphson method?
That will be the topic
of today's lecture.
What's the Newton-Raphson
method look like graphically
in many dimensions.
We talked about this Jacobian.
Right, when we're
trying to find the roots
of a non-linear equation
where our function has
more than one dimension-- let's
say it has two dimensions.
So we have an f 1 and an f 2.
And our unknowns
our x 1 and x 2,
they live in the
x1 x2 plane, right?
f1 might be this say
bowl-shaped function.
I've sketched out in red, right?
It's three dimensional.
It's some surface here.
Right?
We have some initial
guess for the solution.
We go up to the function, and
we find a linearization of it,
which is not a line but a plane.
And that plane intersects
the x 1, x 2 plane at a line.
And our next best guess is going
to live somewhere on this line.
Where on this line depends
on the linearization of f 2.
Right?
So we got to draw the
same picture for f 2,
but I'm not going
to do that for you.
So let's say, this is where
the equivalent line from f 2
intersects the line
from f 1, right?
So the two linearizations
intersect here.
That's our next best guess.
We go back up to the curve.
We find the plane that's
tangent to the curve.
We figure out where
it intersects.
The x 1 x 2 plane.
That's a line.
We find the point on the line
that's our next best guess,
and continue.
Finding that
intersection in the plane
is the act of computing
Jacobian inverse times f.
OK?
If we project down to
just the x 1 x 2 plane,
and we draw the curves where f
1 equals 0, and f 2 equals zero,
right?
Then each of these iterates,
we start with an initial guess.
We find the planes that are
tangent to these curves,
or to these surfaces.
And where they intersect
the x 1 x 2 plane.
Those give us these lines.
And the intersection
of the lines
give us our next approximation.
And so our function steps
along in the x1 and x2 plane.
It takes some path
through that plane.
And eventually it will approach
this locally unique solution.
So that's what this iterative
method is doing, right?
It's navigating this
multidimensional space, right?
It moves where it
has to to satisfy
these linearized
equations, right?
Producing ever better
approximations for a root.
Start close.
It'll converge fast.
How fast?
Quadratically.
And you can prove this.
I'll prove it in 1D.
You might think about the
multidimensional case,
but I'll show you
in one dimension.
So the Newton-Raphson
method said,
xi plus 1 is equal to xi minus
f of xi over f prime of xi.
I'm going to subtract the root,
the exact root from both sides
of this equation.
So this is the absolute error
in the i plus 1 approximation.
It's equal to this.
And we're going to do
a little trick, OK?
The value of the function at the
root is exactly equal to zero,
and I'm going to expand
this as a Taylor series,
about the point xy.
So f of xi plus f prime of
xi times x star minus xi,
plus this second
order term as well.
Plus cubic terms in this
Taylor expansion, right?
All of those need to sum
up and be equal to 0,
Because f of x star
by definition is zero.
x star is the root.
And buried in this
expression here
is a quantity which can be
related to xi minus f of xi
over f prime minus x star.
It's right here, right?
xi minus x star,
xi minus x star.
I've got to divide
through by f prime.
Divide through by f prime,
and I get f over f prime.
That's this guy here.
Those things are equal
in magnitude then,
to this second order term here.
So they are equal
in magnitude to 1/2,
the second derivative of f,
divided by f prime, times xi
minus x star squared.
And then these cubic terms,
well, they're still around.
But they're going to be small as
I get close to the actual root.
So they're negligible, right?
Compared to these second order
terms, they can be neglected.
And you should convince
yourself that I
can apply some of
the norm properties
that we used before, OK?
To the absolute value.
The absolute values is
the norm of a scalar.
So these norm properties
tell me that this quantity
has to be less than
or equal to, right?
This ratio of
derivatives multiplied
by the absolute error
in step i squared.
And I'll divide by that absolute
error in step i squared.
So taking the limit
is i goes to infinity,
this ratio here is
bound by a constant.
This is a definition for
the rate of convergence.
It says I take the absolute
error in step i plus 1.
I divide it by the absolute
error in step i squared.
And it will always be
smaller than some constant,
as i goes to infinity.
So it converges
quadratically, right?
If the relative error in step
i was order 10 to the minus 1,
then the relative
error in step i plus 1
will be order 10 to the minus 2.
Because they got to be
bound by this constant.
If the relative error in
step i was 10 to the minus 2,
the relative error
in step i plus 1,
has got to be order 10 to the
minus 4, or smaller, right?
Because I square the
quantity down here.
I get to double the
number of accurate digits
with each iteration.
And this will hold so long
as the derivative evaluated
at the root is
not equal to zero.
If the derivative evaluated
at the root is equal to zero,
this analysis
wasn't really valid.
You can't divide by zero
in various places, OK?
It turns out the
same thing is true
if we do the
multidimensional case.
I'll leave it to you to
investigate that case.
I think it's interesting for
you to try and explore that.
It follows the 1D model
I showed you before.
But the absolute error
in iterate i plus 1,
divided by the absolute
error in iterate i--
here's a small typo here.
Cross out that plus 1, right?
The absolute error
in iterate i squared
is going to be
bound by a constant.
And this will be true so
long as the determinant
at the Jacobian at the
root is not equal to zero.
We know the determinant
of the Jacobian
plays the role of the
derivative in the 1D case.
When the Jacobian
is singular, you
can show that linear convergence
is going to occur instead.
So it will still converge.
It's not necessarily a
problem that the Jacobian
becomes singular at the root.
But you're going to lose your
rate of quadratic convergence.
And this rate of
convergence is only
guaranteed if we start
sufficiently close to the root.
So good initial guesses,
that's important.
We have a locally
convergent method.
Bad initial guesses?
Well, who knows where
this iterative method is
going to go.
There's nothing to
guarantee that it's
going to converge even.
Right It may run away someplace.
Here are a few examples of
where things can go wrong.
So if I have a local
minima or maxima,
I might have an iterate where
I evaluate the linearization,
and it tells me my
next best approximation
is on the other side of
this minima or maxima.
And then I go up, and I
get the linearization here.
And it tells me, oh, my
next best approximation
is on the other side.
And this method could
bounce back and forth
in here for as long
as we sit and wait.
It's locally convergent,
not globally convergent.
It can get hung up in
situations like this.
Asymptotes are a problem.
I have an asymptote,
which presumably
has an effective root
somewhere out here at infinity.
Well, my solution
would like to follow
the linearization, the
successive linearizations all
the way out along
this asymptote, right?
So my iterates may blow up
in an uncontrolled fashion.
You can also end
up with funny cases
where our Newton-Raphson
steps continually
overshoot the roots.
So they can be functions who
have a power loss scaling
right near the root, such that
the derivative doesn't exist.
OK?
So here the derivative of this
thing, if s is smaller than 1,
and x equals zero, it
won't exist, right?
There isn't a derivative
that's defined there.
And in those cases, you can
often wind up with overshoot.
So I'll take a linearization,
and I'll shoot over the root.
And I'll go up and I'll
take my next linearization,
I'll shoot back on the
other side of the root.
And depending on the power of s
associated with this function,
it may diverge, right?
I may get further and
further away from the root,
or it may slowly converge
towards that root.
But it can be problematic.
Here's another
problem that crops up.
Sometimes people talk
about basins of attraction.
So here's a two-dimensional,
non-linear equation
I want to find the roots for.
It's cubic in
nature, so it's got
three roots, which are indicated
by the stars in the x1 x 2
plane.
And I've taken a number of
different initial guesses
from all over the
plane and I've asked--
given that initial guess, using
the Newton-Raphson method,
which root do I find?
So if you see a dark
blue color like this,
that means initial guesses
there found this root.
If you see a medium
blue color, that
means they found this root.
See a light blue color, that
And this is a relatively
simple function, relatively low
dimension, but the plane
here is tilled by--
it's not tiled.
It's filled with a fractal.
These basins of attraction
are fractal in nature.
Which means that I
could think that I'm
starting with a
solution rate here
that should converge to this
green root because it's close.
But it actually goes over here.
And if I change that initial
guess by a little bit,
it actually pops up to this
root over here instead.
It's quite difficult to
predict which solution
you're going to converge to.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And in this case, you
knew how many roots there are.
JAMES SWAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Often
you wouldn't know.
So you find one,
and you're happy.
Right?
You're happy because
[INAUDIBLE] physical.
Might be the wrong one.
JAMES SWAN: So this the problem.
I think this is about the
minimum level of complexity
you need.
Which is not very complex
at all in a function
to get these sorts of
basins of attraction.
Polynomial equations
are ones that
really suffer from
this especially,
but it's a problem in general.
You often don't know.
I'll show you quasi
Newton-Raphson methods
that help fix some
of these problems.
How about other problems?
It's good to know where
the weaknesses are.
Newton-Raphson sounds great,
but where are the weaknesses?
Let's see.
The Jacobian-- might not be
easy to calculate analytically,
right?
So far we've written
down analytical forms
for the Jacobian.
We've had simple functions.
But maybe it's not easy
to calculate analytically.
You should think about
what are the sources
for this function,
f of x, that we're
trying to find the roots for.
Also we got to
invert the Jacobian,
and we know that's a matrix.
And matrices which have a
lot of dimensions in them
are complicated to invert.
There's a huge
amount of complexity,
computational complexity,
in doing those inversions.
It can take a long
time to do them.
It may undesirable to have
to constantly be solving
a system of linear equations.
So might think about some
options for mitigating this.
Sometimes it won't
converge at all?
Or to the nearest root.
This is this overshoot, or
basin of attraction problem.
And we'll talk about
these modifications
to correct these issues.
They come with a penalty though.
OK?
So Newton-Raphson was
based around the idea
of linearization.
If we modify that
linearization, we're
going to lose some of
these great benefits
of the Newton-Raphson method,
namely that it's quadratically
convergent, right?
We're going to make some
changes to the method,
and it's not going to converge
quadratically anymore.
It's going to slow
down, but maybe we'll
be able to rein in the method
and make it converge either
to the roots we want it to
converge to or converge more
reliably than it would before.
Maybe we'll be able to actually
do the calculation faster,
even though it may
require more iterations.
Maybe we can make each
iteration much faster
using some of these methods.
OK so here are the three things
that we're going to talk about.
We're going to talk about
approximating the Jacobian
with finite differences.
We're talking about
Broyden's method
for approximating the
inverse of the Jacobian.
And we're going to talk
about something called
damped Newton-Raphson methods.
Those will be the three
topics of the day.
So here's what I said before.
Analytical calculations
of Jacobian
requires analytical
formulas for f.
And for functions of a
few dimensions, right?
These calculations
are not too tough.
For functions of
many dimensions,
this is tedious at best.
Error prone, at worst.
Think about even something like
10 equations for 10 unknowns.
If your error rate is
1%, well, you're shot.
There's a pretty good
chance that you missed
one element of the Jacobian.
You made a mistake
somewhere in there.
And now you're not
doing Newton-Raphson
You're doing some other
iterative method that isn't
the one that you intended.
There are a lot of times
where you-- maybe you
have an analytical formula for
some of these f's, but not all
of them.
So where can these
functionalities come from?
We've seen some cases, where
you have physical models.
Thermodynamic models that
you can write down by hand.
But where are other places
that these functions come from?
Ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: Oh, good.
JAMES SWAN: Beautiful.
So this is going to be the
most common case, right?
Maybe you want to use some
sort of simulation code, right?
To model something.
It's somebody else's
simulation code.
They're an expert at doing
finite element modeling.
But the output is this f
that you're interested,
and the input to the
simulation are these x's.
And you want to find the roots
associated with this problem
that you're solving via
the simulation code, right?
This is pretty important
being able to connect
different pieces of
software together.
Well, there's no analytical
formula for f there.
OK?
You're shot.
So it may come from
results of simulations.
This is extremely common.
It could come from
interpretation of data.
So you may have a
bunch of data that's
being generated by some physical
measurement or a process,
either continuously or
you just have a data set
that's available to you.
But these function
values are often not,
they're not things that
you know analytically.
It may also be the case that,
oh, man, even Aspen, you're
going to wind up solving
systems of nonlinear equations.
It's going to use the
Newton-Raphson method.
Aspen's going to have lots
of these formulas in it
for functions.
Whose going in by
hand and computing
the derivatives of all
these functions for aspen?
MATLAB has a nonlinear
equation solver in it.
You give it the
function, and it'll
find the root of the
equation, given a guess.
It's going to use the
Newton-Raphson method.
Whose computing the
Jacobian for MATLAB?
You can.
You can compute it by
hand, and give it an input.
Sometimes that's a
really good thing to do.
But sometimes, we don't
have that available to us.
So we need alternative ways
of computing the Jacobian.
The simplest one is a finite
difference approximation.
So you recall the definition
of the derivative.
It's the limit of this
difference, f of x plus epsilon
minus f of x divided by epsilon,
as epsilon goes to zero.
There's an error in
this approximation
for the derivative with a
finite value for epsilon,
which is proportional
to epsilon.
So choose a small
value of epsilon.
You'll get a good approximation
for the derivative.
It turns out the accuracy
depends on epsilon,
but kind of in a
non-intuitive way.
And here's a simple example.
So let's compute the
derivative of f of x equals e
the x, which is e to the x.
Let's evaluate it at x equals 1.
So
F prime of 1 is e the 1,
which should approximately
be e to the 1 plus epsilon
minus e to the 1 over epsilon.
And here I've done
this calculation.
And I've asked, what's
the absolute error
in this calculation by taking
the difference between this
and this, for different
values of epsilon.
You can see initially,
as epsilon gets smaller,
the absolute error goes down
in proportion to epsilon.
10 to the minus 3,
10 to the minus 3.
10 to the minus 4,
10 to the minus 4.
10 to the minus 8,
10 to the minus 8.
10 to the minus 9.
10 to the minus 7.
10 to the minus 10.
And 10 to the minus 6.
So it went down,
and it came back up.
But that's not what this formula
told us should happen, right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So just to be sure.
That term in that
column on the right?
JAMES SWAN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: It says
exponential 1, but it
represents the approximation?
JAMES SWAN: Exponential 1 is
exponential 1. f prime of 1
is our approximation here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
JAMES SWAN: Sorry
that that's unclear.
Yes, so this is the absolute
error in this approximation.
So it goes down,
and then it goes up.
Is that clear now?
Good.
OK, why does it go down?
It goes down because our
definition of the derivative
says it should go down.
At some point, I've actually
got to do these calculations
with high enough accuracy
to be able to perceive
the difference between e to
the 1 plus, 10 to the minus 9,
and e to the 1.
So there is a truncation
error in the calculation
of this difference that reduces
my accuracy at a certain level.
There's a heuristic
you can use here, OK?
You want to set
this epsilon when
you do this finite
difference approximation,
to be the square
root of the machine
precision times the magnitude
of x, the point at which you're
trying to calculate
this derivative.
So that's, usually
we're double precision.
So this is something
like 10 to the minus 8
times the magnitude of x.
That's pretty good.
That holds true here.
OK?
You can test it out on
some other functions.
If x is 0, or very small.
We don't want a
relative tolerance.
We've got to choose an
absolute tolerance instead.
Just like we talked about
with the step norm criteria.
So one has to be a
little bit careful
in how you implement this.
But this is a good guide, OK?
A good way to think about how
the error is going to go down,
and where it's going to
start to come back up.
Make sense?
Good.
OK, so how do you compute
elements of the Jacobian then?
Well, those are all
just partial derivatives
of the function with respect to
one of the unknown variables.
So partial f i with
respect to x j is just
f i at x plus some
epsilon deviation of x
in its j-th component only.
So this is like a unit
vector in the j direction,
or associated with the j-th
element of this vector.
Minus f i of x divided
by this epsilon.
Equivalently, you'd
have to do this for f i.
You can compute all the
columns of the Jacobian
very quickly by calling
f of x plus epsilon
minus f of x over epsilon.
Just evaluate your vector-valued
function at these different
x's.
Take the difference,
and that will give you
column j of your Jacobian.
So how many function
evaluations does it
take to calculate the
Jacobian at a single point?
How many times do I have
to evaluate my function?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 2 n.
JAMES SWAN: 2n, right.
So if I have n, if I
have n elements to x,
I've got to make two function
calls per column of j.
There's going to
be n columns in j.
So 2n function evaluations
to compute the Jacobian
at a single point.
Is that really true though?
Not quite.
f of x is f of x.
I don't have to
compute it every time.
I just compute f of x once.
So it's really like n plus
1 that I have to do, right?
N plus a function evaluations
to compute this thing.
I actually got to
compute them though.
Function evaluations
may be really expensive.
Suppose you're doing some sort
of complicated simulation,
like a finite
element simulation.
Maybe it takes minutes to
generate a function evaluation.
So it can be
expensive to compute
the Jacobian in this way.
Just be expensive to
compute the Jacobian.
How is approximation
of Jacobian going
to affect the convergence?
What's going to happen to
the rate of convergence
of our method?
It's going to go down, right?
It's probably not
going to be linear.
It's not going to be quadratic.
It's going to be some
super linear factor.
It's going to depend on how
accurate the Jacobian is.
How sensitive the
function is near the root.
But it's going to reduce
the accuracy of the method,
or the convergence rate of
the method by a little bit.
That's OK.
So this is what MATLAB does.
It uses a finite
difference approximation
for your Jacobian.
When you give it a function,
and you don't tell it
the Jacobian explicitly.
Here's an example of how
to implement this yourself.
So I've got to have
some function that
does whatever this
function is supposed to do.
It takes as input x and
it gives an output f.
And then the Jacobian, right?
It's a matrix.
So we initialize this matrix.
We loop over each
of the columns.
We compute the
displacement right?
The deviation from
x for each of these.
And then we compute
this difference
and divide it by epsilon.
I haven't done everything
perfect here, right?
Here's an extra
function evaluation.
I could just calculate
the value of the function
at x before doing the loop.
I've also only used a
relative tolerance here.
I'm going to be in
trouble if xi is 0.
It's going to be a problem
with this algorithm.
These are the little details
one has to pay attention to.
But it's a simple enough
calculation to do.
Loop over the columns, right?
Compute these differences.
Divide by epsilon.
You have your approximation
for the Jacobian.
I've got to do that at
every iteration, right?
Every time x is updated, I've
got to recompute my Jacobian.
That's it though.
All right, that's one way
of approximating a Jacobian.
There s a method that's used in
one dimension called the Secant
method.
It's a special case of
the Newton-Raphson method
and uses a coarser approximation
for the derivative.
It says, I was taking these
steps from xi minus 1 to xi.
And I knew the
function values there.
Maybe I should just
compute the slope
of the line that goes through
those points, and say,
that's my approximation
for the derivative.
Why not?
I have the data available to me.
It seems like a
sensible thing to do.
So we replace f prime at x1 with
f of xi minus f of x i minus 1.
Down here we put xi
minus xi minus 1 up here.
That's our approximation
for the derivative,
or the inverse of
the derivative.
This can work, it
can work just fine.
Can it be extended
to many dimensions?
That's an interesting
question, though?
This is simple.
In many dimensions,
not so obvious right?
If I know xi, xi minus 1.
f of xi, f of si minus 1.
Can I approximate the Jacobian?
What do you think?
Does it strike you
as though there
might be some fundamental
difficulty to doing that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you
approximate the gradient?
[INAUDIBLE] gradient of f at x.
JAMES SWAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: But I'm sure
if you whether you
can go backwards from the
gradient in the Jacobian.
JAMES SWAN: OK.
So, let's-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Perhaps
the difficulty is,
I mean when they're
just single values--
JAMES SWAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can think of
[INAUDIBLE] derivative, right?
JAMES SWAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
get really big,
you get a vector of
a function at xi,
a vector of a function of
xi minus 1 or whatever.
Vectors of these x's.
And so if you're [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: Yeah, so how
do I divide these things?
That's a good question.
The Jacobian-- how much
information content
is in the Jacobian?
Or how many
independent quantities
are built into the Jacobian?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: And squared.
And how much data do I
have to work with here?
You know, order n data.
To figure out order
n squared quantities.
This is the division problem
you're describing, right?
So it seems like this is
an underdetermined sort
of problem.
And it is.
OK?
So there isn't a direct
analog to the Secant method
in dimensions.
We can write down
something that makes sense.
So this is the 1D
Secant approximation.
That the value of the
derivative multiplied
by the step between
i minus 1 and i
is approximated
by the difference
in the values of the function.
The equivalent is the value
of the Jacobian multiplied
by the step between
i minus 1 and i
is equal to the difference
between the values
of the functions.
But now this is
an equation for n
squared elements
of the Jacobian,
in terms of n elements
of the function, right?
So it's massively,
massively underdetermined.
OK?
Here we have an equation for--
we have one equation
for one unknown.
The derivative, right?
Think about how it was moving
through space before, right?
The difference here, xi minus 1,
that's some sort of linear path
that I'm moving
along through space.
How am I supposed to figure out
what the tangent curves to all
these functions are
from this linear path
through multidimensional
space, right?
That's not going to work.
So there's
underdetermined problems.
It's not so-- that's
not so bad, actually.
Right?
Doesn't mean
there's no solution.
In fact, it means there's
all a lot of solutions.
So we can pick whichever
one we think is suitable.
And Broyden's method
is a method for picking
one of these
potential solutions to
this underdetermined problem.
We don't have enough information
to calculate the Jacobian
exactly.
But maybe we can construct a
suitable approximation for it.
And here's what's done.
So here's the Secant
approximation.
It says the Jacobian
times the step
size, or the
Newton-Raphson step,
should be the difference
in the functions.
And Newton's method for x
i, said xi minus xi minus 1
was equal-- times
the Jacobian, was
equal to minus f of xi minus 1.
This is just Newton's method.
Invert the Jacobian, and
put it on the other side
of the equation.
Broyden's method said,
i-- there's a trick here.
Take the difference
between these things.
I get the same left-hand side
on both of these equations.
So take the difference,
and I can figure out
how the Jacobian should change
from one step to the next.
So maybe I have a good
approximation to the Jacobian
at xi minus i, I might
be able to use this still
underdetermined problem
to figure out how
to update that Jacobian, right?
So Broyden's method is what's
referred to as the rank one
update.
You should convince
yourself that letting
the Jacobian at xi minus
the Jacobian at xi minus 1
be equal to this is
one possible solution
of this underdetermined
equation.
There are others.
This is one possible solution.
It turns out to be a
good one to choose.
So there's an
iterative approximation
now for the Jacobian.
Does this strategy make sense?
It's a little weird, right?
There's something tricky here.
You got to know to do this.
Right, so somebody
has to have in mind
already that they're looking
for differences in the Jacobian
that they're going
to update over time.
So this tells me the Jacobian,
how the Jacobian is updated.
Really we need the
Jacobian inverse,
and the reason for choosing
this rank one update
approximation is it's
possible to write
the inverse of j of xi in
terms of the inverse of j
at xi minus 1 when this
update formula is true.
So it's something called the
Sherman Morrison Formula, which
says the inverse of a matrix
plus the dyadic product of two
vectors can be
written in this form.
We don't need to derive
this, but this is true.
This matrix plus dyadic
product is exactly this.
We have dyadic product
between f and the step
from xi minus 1 to x.
And so we can apply that
Sherman Morrison Formula
to the rank one update.
And not only can we update
the Jacobian iteratively,
but we can update
the Jacobian inverse.
So if I know j inverse
at some previous time,
I know j inverse at
some later time too.
I don't have to
compute these things.
I don't have to solve these
systems of equations, right?
I just update this matrix.
Update this matrix,
and I can very rapidly
do these computations.
So not only do we have
an iterative formula
for the steps, right?
From x 0 to x1 to x 2,
all the way up to our
converged solution,
but we can have
a formula for the
inverse of the Jacobian.
We give up accuracy.
But that's paid for in
terms of the amount of time
we have to spend doing
these calculations.
Does it pay off?
It depends on the
problem, right?
We try to solve problems
in different ways.
This is a pretty common way
to approximate the Jacobian.
Questions about this?
No.
OK.
Broyden's method.
All right, here's the last one.
The Damped
Newton-Raphson method.
We'll do this in one dimension.
So the Newton-Raphson method,
Newton and Raphson told us,
take a step from xi to xi
plus 1 that is this big.
xi to xi plus 1, it's this big.
Sometimes you'll take
that step, and you'll
find that the value of
the function at xi plus 1
is even bigger than the
value of the function at xi.
There was nothing about the
Newton-Raphson method that
told us the function value was
always going to be decreasing.
But actually, our goal is to
make the function value go
to 0 in absolute value.
So it seems like this step,
not a very good one, right?
What are Newton and
Raphson thinking here.
This is not a good idea.
The function value went up.
Far from a root, OK?
The Newton-Raphson
method is going
to give these sorts
of erratic responses.
Who knows what direction
it's going to go?
And it's only
locally convergent.
It tells us a
direction to move in,
but it doesn't always give
the right sort of magnitude
associated with that step.
And so you take these
steps and you can find out
the value of your function, the
normed value of your functions.
It's bigger than
where you started.
It seems like you're getting
further away from the root.
Our ultimate goal is to
drive this norm to 0.
So steps like that you might
even call unacceptable.
Right?
Why would I ever take a
step in that direction?
Maybe I should use
a different method.
When I take a step that's
so big my function value
grows in norm value.
So what one does, oftentimes,
is introduce a damping factor,
right?
We said that this
ratio, or equivalently,
the Jacobian inverse times
the value of the function,
gives us the right
direction to step in.
But how big a step
should we take?
It's clear a step like
this is a good one.
It reduced the value
of the function.
And it's better than
the one we took before,
which was given by the
linear approximation.
So if I draw the tangent
line, it intercepts here.
If I take a step
in this direction,
but I reduce the
slope by having some
damping factor that's
smaller than 1,
I get closer to the root.
Ideally we'd like to
choose that damping factor
to be the one that minimizes
the value of the function at xi
plus 1.
So it's the argument
that minimizes
the value of the function at xi
plus 1 or at xi minus alpha, f
over f prime.
Solving that
optimization problem,
what's hard as finding
the root itself.
So ideally this is true.
But practically you're not
going to be able to do it.
So we have to come up with some
approximate methods of solving
this optimization problem.
Actually we don't even care
about getting it exact.
We know Newton-Raphson
does a pretty good job.
We want some sort
of guess that's
respectable for this alpha so
that we get close to this root.
Once we get close,
we'll probably
choose alpha equal to 1.
We'll just take the
Newton-Raphson steps
all the way down to the root.
So here it is in
many dimensions.
Modify the Newton-Raphson
step by some value alpha,
choose alpha to be
the argument that
minimizes the norm value of
the function at xi plus 1.
Here's one way of doing this.
So this is called the
Armijo line search.
See?
Line search.
Start by letting
alpha equal to 1.
Take the full Newton-Raphson
step, and check.
Was the value of my function
smaller than where I started?
If it is, let's take the step.
It's getting us-- we're
accomplishing our goal.
We re reducing the value
of the function in norm.
Maybe we're headed towards z.
That's good.
Accept it.
If no, let's replace
alpha with alpha over 2.
Let's take a shorter step.
We take a shorter
step, and we repeat.
Right?
Take the shorter step.
Check whether the value of the
function with the shorter step
is acceptable.
If yes, let's take
it, and let's move on.
And if no, replace alpha with
alpha over 2, and continue.
So we have our step
size every time.
We don't just have to have it.
We could choose different
factors to reduce it by.
But we try to take
shorter and shorter steps
until we accomplish our goal
of having a function which
is smaller in norm
at our next iterate
than where we were before.
It's got-- the function
value will be reduced.
The Newton-Raphson
method picks a direction
that wants to bring the
function value closer to 0.
We linearize the
function, and we
found the direction we needed
to go to make that linearization
go to 0.
So there is a step size
for which the function
value will be reduced.
And because of that,
this Armijo line search
of the Damped
Newton-Raphson method
is actually globally
convergent, right?
The iterative method
will terminate.
You can guarantee it.
Here's what it looks
like graphically.
I take my big step, my
alpha equals 1 step.
I check the value
of the function.
It's bigger in absolute
value than where I started.
So I go back.
I take half that step size.
OK?
I look at the value
of the function.
It's still bigger.
Let's reject it, and go back.
I take half that
step size again.
The value of the
function here is now
smaller in absolute value.
So I accept it.
And I put myself pretty
close to the root.
So it's convergent,
globally convergent.
That's nice.
It's not globally convergent
to roots, which is a pain.
But it's globally convergent.
It will terminate eventually.
You'll get to a
point where you won't
be able to advance
your steps any further.
It may converge to minima
or maxima of a function.
Or it may converge to roots.
But it will converge.
I showed you this example before
with basins of attraction.
So here we have different
basins of attraction.
They're all colored in.
They show you which
roots you approach.
Here I've applied the
Damped Newton-Raphson method
to the same system of equations.
And you can see the
basins of attraction
are shrunk because
of the damping.
What happens when you're
very close to places where
the determinant of the
Jacobian is singular,
you take all sorts
of wild steps.
You go to places where
the value of the function
is bigger than
where you started.
And then you've got to
step down from there
to try to find the root.
Who knows where
those locations are?
It's a very complicated,
geometrically complicated space
that you're moving through.
And the Damped
Newton-Raphson method
is forcing the steps
to always reduce
the value of the
function, so they
reduce the size of these
basins of attraction.
So this is often a
nice way to supplement
the Newton-Raphson method
when your guesses aren't
very good to begin with.
When you start to get close
to root you're, always just
going to accept alpha equals 1.
The first step will
be the best step,
and then you'll converge
very rapidly to the solution.
Do we have to do any
extra work actually
to do this Damped
Newton-Raphson method.
Does it require
extra calculations?
What do you think?
A lot of extra-- a lot
of extra calculation?
How many extra calculations
does it require?
Of course it requires extra.
How many?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: What do you think?
JAMES SWAN: It's--
that much is true.
So let's talk about
taking one step.
How many more-- how many
more calculations do
I have to pay to do
this sort of a step?
Or even write the
multidimensional step?
For each of these
times around this loop,
do I have to recompute?
Do I have to solve the
system of equations?
No.
Right?
You precompute this, right?
This is the basic
Newton-Raphson step.
You compute that first.
You've got to do it once.
And then it's pretty
cheap after that.
I've got to do some extra
function evaluations,
but I don't actually have to
solve the system of equations.
Remember this is order n cubed.
If we solve it exactly, maybe
order n squared or order
n if we do it iteratively.
And the Jacobian
is sparse somehow,
and we know about
it sparsity pattern.
This is expensive.
Function evaluations, those
are order n to compute.
Relatively cheap by comparison.
So you compute
your initial step.
That's expensive.
But all of this down
here is pretty cheap.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You're also assuming
that your function evaluations
are reasonably true.
JAMES SWAN: This is true.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: It's true.
Well, Jacobian is also very
expensive to compute then too.
So, if--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: Sure, sure, sure.
No, I don't disagree.
I think one has to pick
the method you're going
to use to suit the problem.
But turns out this doesn't
involve much extra calculation.
So by default, for
example, fsolve in MATLAB
is going to do this for you.
Or some version of this.
it's going to try to take
steps that aren't too big.
It will limit the
step size for you,
so that it keeps the value
of the function reducing
in magnitude.
It's a pretty good
general strategy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so why
do we just pick one value for
[INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: I see.
So why-- ask that one more time.
This is a good question.
Can you say it a little
louder so everyone can hear?
AUDIENCE: So why, instead of
having just one value of alpha
and not having several
values of alpha [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: I see.
So the question is, yeah,
we used a scalar alpha here,
right?
If we wanted to, we could
reduce the step size
and also change direction.
We would use a matrix to
do that, instead, right?
It would transform the step
and change its direction.
And maybe we would
choose different alphas
along different
directions, for example.
So diagonal matrix
with different alphas.
We could potentially do that.
we're probably going to
need some extra information
to decide how to set the
scaling in different directions.
One thing we know for sure is
that the Newton-Raphson step
will reduce the value
of the function.
If we take a small
enough step size,
it will bring the value
of the function down.
We know that because
we did the Taylor
Expansion of the function
to determine that step size.
And that Taylor expansion
was going to be--
that Taylor expansion is
nearly exact in the limit
of very, very small step sizes.
So there will always
be some small step
in this direction,
which will reduce
the value of the function.
In other directions,
we may reduce the value
of the function faster.
We don't know which
directions to choose, OK?
Actually I shouldn't say that.
When we take very small step
sizes in this direction,
it's reducing the value
of the function fastest.
There isn't a faster
direction to go in.
When we take impossibly small,
vanishingly small step sizes.
But in principle, if I
had some extra information
on the problem, I might be
able to choose step sizes
along different directions.
I may know that one
of these directions
is more ill-behaved
than the other ones.
And choose a different
damping factor for it.
That's a possibility.
But we actually have
to know something
about the details of
the problem we're trying
to solve if we're going to do--
it's a wonderful question.
I mean, you could
think about ways
of making this more,
potentially more robust.
I'll show you an alternative
way of doing this when
we talk about optimization.
In optimization we'll
do-- we'll solve
systems of nonlinear equations
to solve these optimization
problems.
There's another way of doing
the same sort of strategy that's
more along what
you're describing.
Maybe there's a
different direction
to choose instead that
could be preferable.
This is something called
the dogleg method.
Great question.
Anything else?
No.
So globally convergent, right?
Converges to roots,
local minima or maxima.
There are other modifications
that are possible.
We'll talk about
them in optimization.
There's always a
penalty to doing this.
The penalty is in the
rate of convergence.
So it will converge more slowly.
But maybe you speed the
calculations along anyways,
right?
Maybe it requires fewer
iterations overall
to get there because
you tame the locally
convergent properties of
the Newton-Raphson method.
Or you shortcut some of
the expensive calculations,
like getting your Jacobian
or calculating your Jacobian
inverse.
All right?
So Monday we're going to review
sort of topics up til now.
Professor Green will run
the lecture on Monday.
And then after
that, we'll pick up
with optimization, which will
follow right on from what
we've done so far.
Thanks.